all right this is a call that came in
thank you for hitting the hotline as as
always the hotline is 98566
49503 let's hear this hey Theo my name
is Alex I'm from Denmark and Denmark
baby Denmark did it yeah Ricky done it
Denmark did
it onward brother um I have two
questions for you number one I have
Asbergers so I'm all ISM out baby as you
would say damn baby you got the Euro ISM
baby
gang
bro we never [__] had that [__] on it
bro we never had the exchange rate on
that freaking tism bro that tiim or
whatever they call it over there you
know we never had that exchange rate on
that t we never had that [__] baby we
never had it so God good to see you baby
[__] deuts Mark baby with that
TM [__] yeah dude I knew that [__] would
make it overseas baby you're all gonna
[__] get it praise God boy we're all
going to be playing [__] Zelda
Somewhere In Hell Baby Let's Hear It
onward sorry man
sorry onward this mouth baby as you
would say which I love by the way um how
would you go about a first date like how
would you ensure that date doesn't tism
out fully my second question to you is
well first of all this how you do a
first date man you don't do no you don't
try to do no sex you don't try to do no
titty you don't try to do no booty hole
or nothing you do regular you do
communication you do uh constant
um uh positive energy you know you do
learning get some coffee and uh maybe
have a uh
oh [__] it's up already
snack have a snack you got to do
something easy drop somebody off get
them an Uber don't try to make all the
magic
happen don't because there's no magic
left in the sack
homie there's no magic left in the sack
baby you got to leave some magic in the
sack so that's what I would do and if
you have autism or whatever you got baby
asberg
[__] Burgers whatever you got dog
[__] one of the wall bers one of
them's got the [__] Ronnie or
whatever uh tell them straight up hey
baby you know I'm that [__] I'm that
[__] Spectrum donkey
homie tell her straight up tell her show
her where you at on the Spectrum bring a
ruler you know so that'll help baby
you're gonna be fine baby I'll tell a
lot of chicks will they'll love a do
with who got a [__] problem as long
as it's an energetic one as long as if
you do yard work and you [__] get out
there and you build a damn uh a travoli
fountain or whatever out of the leaves
or some kind of [__] she's gonna love
you dude if you be build a uh arch of
trium out of the damn um you know out of
some [__] you supposed to pull out of
the garage she going to love you brother
and that's God working with you onward
um
I've noticed in your latest few videos
you're wearing these really cool black
Aviator style sunglasses I was curious
could you share the brand and M of those
because I would love to get them for
myself carry a bit of Theo swag on my
day hell yeah baby and these are these
autism [__] blinders
baby these are autism blinders dog they
see me
teing they
ha bro
knock knock who's there
autism where the hoes
at not
here